foreign
[Music]
Fogerty and I'm a bioinformatician at
Mayo Clinic in Rochester Minnesota
today I'll be spending some time talking
about antibody drug conjugates and an
example of a recent application of
antibody drug conjugates and breast
cancer treatment
I don't have any Financial disclosures
or any conflict of interest disclosures
to report today
I'll start off with a quick introduction
to antibody based cancer therapies a few
examples of mechanisms by which
antibodies either directly or indirectly
lead to cancer cell death
and a few examples of the types of
antibodies that are used
then I'll describe antibody drug
conjugates and how they work
and I'll mention a few recent
developments regarding the use of
antibody drug conjugates in the
treatment of breast cancer
there are many different treatments for
cancer and even different types of
treatment for cancer along with options
like chemotherapy and radiation therapy
there's also a class of antibody-based
targeted Therapies as the name implies
targeted therapy refers to cancer
treatment that targets proteins that
control cancer cell growth
an antibody based targeted therapies use
antibodies rather than small molecule
drugs to do that targeting of those
cancer cells
so what is an antibody
an antibody is a particular type of
protein that works as part of our immune
system and it recognizes and binds
tightly to an antigen
in the context of cancer treatment that
antigen is present on the surface of a
cancer cell
and ideally not present on the surface
of other cells
and from there there's different
Pathways for an antibody to neutralize
or destroy or kill that cancer cell on
this Slide the antibodies are the purple
y-shaped things that appear in a handful
of different places always binding to a
red tumor antigen on the cell surface
antibodies are naturally occurring but
when it comes to cancer treatment
they're generally produced and purified
in a lab somewhere that way we can get
large quantities of the particular
antibodies that we're interested in for
a particular purpose
one mechanism for antibody related
immune response is antibody dependent
cellular cytotoxicity which is also
sometimes referred to as antibody
dependent cell-mediated cytotoxicity
in this case antibodies bind to antigens
on the surface of a cancer cell
and then an immune cell typically a
natural killer cell or maybe a
macrophage the immune cell recognizes
those bound antibodies
comes closer comes into contact and then
begins a process to lyse that cancer
cell where the antibodies are found
in this case the antibody is not
exerting any anti-tumor activity on its
own
it's really just serving as a marker to
sort of flag down help from immune cells
and then the immune cells can do that
anti-tumor activity
another mechanism is complement
dependent cytotoxicity
where there's a c1q protein complex
which binds to the antibodies which have
bound to the antigens on the cell
surface
and then the antibodies plus that
protein complex form a membrane attack
complex
and that membrane attack complex then
disrupts the cell membrane of that
targeted cancer cell creating pores in
the membrane and leading to death of
that cancer cell
and in both of these cases
the antibodies are really working in
conjunction with another component
another part of the body either the
immune cell or this protein complex in
order to kill that Target cell
but an antibody can also have a more
direct impact
when they have bound to a cell surface
antigen some antibodies can physically
block a signaling pathway or inhibit
some sort of a cell growth pathway
and lead to cell death
these antibodies are relatively large
proteins and they they physically get in
the way once they're bound to the
antigen and just like physically inhibit
block
some sort of signaling or some sort of
uh pathway for cell growth
and whether this antibody is involved in
an indirect or a direct mechanism of
action there's definitely potential here
to exploit their natural behavior as a
use of a targeted therapy with their
affinity for particular antigens on that
cell surface
we have lots and lots of antibodies
naturally occurring and circulating
through our bloodstream that's just part
of our immune system
these antibodies recognize pathogens and
all kinds of bad stuff
in order to keep us healthy any sort of
foreign
disease-causing sort of thing will have
antibodies to help neutralize that
threat
and
they recognize these antigens with a
high specificity
so one opportunity for treatment for
cancer treatment is to create a whole
bunch of monoclonal antibodies in a lab
sort of engineered them synthetically
to Target a particular a particular
cancer cell antigen
and this production and isolation and
purification is all done in a lab
somewhere to mass produce these things
depending on the antibody
it might recruit other immune cells like
I had said earlier and enable those
immune cells to kill a cancer cell
or the antibody might have that direct
impact where it's inhibiting other
Pathways and and blocking cell growth
leading to cancer cell death
by specific antibodies
can be engineered to simultaneously bind
to two different antigens whereas a
general antibody binds to one thing
with its y-shaped design
by specific antibody combined to two
different antigens the most widely used
application here is to bind a T Cell on
one side and then a cancer cell antigen
on the other side
that way the antibody is bringing the T
Cell sufficiently close to the cancer
cell and then the T cell can kill the
cancer cell
just once it's uh in close proximity
another another topic that has been
creating some excitement that was gotten
research it's gotten Publications is
chimeric antigen receptors which are
engineered to produce an artificial t
cell receptor
and this isn't quite an antibody per se
but it augments a T Cell by giving it an
antigen receptor which behaves much like
an antibody
and then in this car T Cell Therapy
modified T cells are able to better
recognize cancer cells in order to more
efficiently find and destroy those
cancer cells
uh it's a lot like the the typical
antibody Behavior where it binds to the
cancer cell antigen
but in this case instead of an antibody
it's sort of the T Cell itself is
recognizing that cancer cell antigen and
uh allowing the T Cell to destroy that
cancer cell
but my focus today will be on antibody
drug conjugates rather than monoclonal
antibodies or car T cells
therapy
so an antibody drug conjugate is a
therapeutic agent composed of a
monoclonal antibody linked to some sort
of a cytotoxic payload via a chemical
Linker
so it has those three components an
antibody a Linker and a drug
and the idea here goes back to a over
100 year old idea of a Magic Bullet
treatment that could specifically Target
some disease-causing thing while
avoiding any harm for the rest of the
body
instead of just giving a drug with
potential for side effects an off-target
toxicity the goal here with an antibody
drug conjugate is to deliver that drug
to only the cancer cells that you're
trying to destroy
use the antibody for that specificity to
find the cancer cells
and then use the drug to kill the cancer
and of course there are many things to
consider
the antigen that you're targeting should
be highly expressed in the tumor tissue
but not expressed or may be expressed at
low levels and normal tissues
you don't want any sort of On Target but
off tumor toxicity where the antigen is
present in healthy tissue if that
targeted antigen is present in normal
tissue you might end up delivering the
drug and killing the normal tissue the
healthy tissue in addition to killing
the tumor cells that you're trying to
kill and that sort of toxicity is
something we we try to avoid with these
targeted Therapies
also you need a Linker that keeps these
antibodies and their payload held
together as they're delivered into the
bloodstream and on route to their target
wherever that tumor tissue happens to be
but then you also want that Linker to be
cleaved and released the payload that
cytotoxic payload once it gets to its
destination once you're at the tumor
cell that's the time to turn the drug
loose
and then you want the right drug too
that right cytotoxic payload depending
on the cancer there's maybe a different
pathway or something specific that you
want to Target in order to kill those
cancer cells
with an antibody drug conjugate the idea
of the antibody as a therapy by itself
is really taking a back seat to the idea
of using the antibody as a delivery
vehicle
you still have the drug to act as the
drug but the antibody is a way to limit
the toxicity of that drug by getting it
to where it needs to go right to the
individual cells where the drug is
needed
and again this is trying to watch out
for any sort of On Target but off tumor
toxicity
if your antigen is expressed elsewhere
in the body
you could get that off tumor but still
on target
drug delivery
this figure is just showing a few of the
ways to combine these three different
components to create an effective
antibody drug conjugate at the top left
is a cartoon showing the intact
conjugate the antibody is the big
y-shaped part in green the cytotoxic
payload is the yellow star and those
little blue sections are the linkers
holding it together
and as I said there's different
properties to consider when you're
choosing an antibody
things like stability of the antibody
stability of the conjugate
binding affinities and affinities for
those antigens those are all
lots of things that can have an impact
into how efficient these antibody drug
conjugates are as as Therapies
and the linkers can have different
properties too
you can have a cleavable Linker or a
non-cleavable Linker uh cleavable might
mean that it
the Linker can get cut based on
different environmental conditions or it
can get cut by a certain enzyme
and a non-cleavable Linker might be a
little bit stronger of a bond
leading to higher stability like keeping
that conjugate intact with all three
components
and helping you to get more of that drug
delivered into the tumor tissue
and then then there's the cytotoxic
payload itself
which can Target different different
components different cellular components
different Pathways in this figure it's
looking at microtubules or DNA cleavage
as a mechanism for killing off the
cancer cell
so as much as we'd like these antibody
drug conjugates to always be held
together and stay intact with all three
pieces like the previous slide
they do sometimes circulate the
bloodstream as three separate components
where one component is the intact
conjugate with the three pieces all held
together antibody Linker drug
but you can also have the antibody by
itself you could also have the drug by
itself
this isn't this isn't ideal but as these
molecules circulate throughout the body
there's some potential to dissociate the
the components here into separate pieces
ideally you want that Linker to be
strong enough to keep everything intact
before it gets cleaved at the right time
at the right place
rather than allowing it to separate into
the antibody and the drug in separate
pieces ahead of time uh you know based
on that environmental conditions or an
enzyme
you want everything to stay intact for
as long as it can to get into the target
cell
as these antibody drug conjugates
diffuse through the bloodstream and
towards their cancer cells uh that
cytotoxic payload can potentially be
released into the tumor microenvironment
uh sort of getting close to the tumors
that's not quite the goal that's not
quite the intended destination uh it's
close but ideally getting the drug into
the cancer cell and getting that whole
antibody conjugate
into the cell is is the end point that
we're looking for
so we hope that it all stays intact
to allow that antibody to pair up with
the tumor cell surface antigen and get
the drug to that cell and into that cell
not just to the environment in that
tumor tissue
so depending on the antibody as I
mentioned earlier those antibodies might
have some anti-tumor anti-cancer
activity on their own these antibodies
might still even as an intact conjugate
these antibodies might still recruit
immune cells into that area
bringing in a T cell or a natural killer
cell
or they might have that direct impact
where they inhibit a cellular pathway or
they block some sort of signaling that
that's vital for a cancer cell
uh so you do get that
antibody as a therapy potentially
but that's not here that's not the
primary goal here for these conjugates
the real goal is the right side of this
panel
ideally the conjugates will bind to that
antigen on the cell surface
and then get pulled into the cancer cell
via endocytosis
and that should be intact the antibody
the Linker the payload altogether once
it gets brought into the cell
once that intact conjugate has been
brought into the cell the Linker is
designed to release the payload to be
cleaved
to release the payload so that it could
the payload the drug can take its effect
on the cancer cell and result in death
of that cell
the payload might as we saw in the other
slide with the examples it might impact
the microtubule function or it might
result in DNA cleavage in the nucleus
uh you know whatever that mechanism is
for the drug once it gets into the
into the cell that's the drugs time to
shine
and one additional sort of bonus
depending on the drug depending on the
properties of the drug
it might be able to exit the cell that
it came into
go into a neighboring cell and then
begin it that's that cell killing
process within the neighboring cell
and I know I mentioned we really want to
get that drug to the Target cell it's
not quite good enough to just get close
get into the tumor area
but here with this
uh what when the drug is designed to
take out the cell that it gets brought
into and get the cell nearby we're
getting that Target cell that has the
antigen expression as well as cancer
cells in the area sort of extending the
power of that treatment
more bang for your buck
and as you see on the right panel
this antibody drug conjugate all three
pieces antibody Linker payload has
gotten pulled into a tumor cell and that
tumor cell has many antigens on its
surface so that antibody is able to find
that cell bind to the antigen get
brought inside
and once it's inside
some of that drug stays there to kill
off the cell and some of the drug is
able to move into a neighboring cell
that doesn't have the high expression of
antigens on the cell surface
so this bystander effect can really be a
powerful benefit as a cancer therapy
particularly when the antigen that
you're targeting has heterogeneous
expression within the tumor tissue
so now you don't necessarily need a high
expression of the antigen everywhere in
the tumor as long as there's High
expression of the antigen and some of
the tumor you can still get that desired
cytotoxic effect everywhere because
you're getting
the the high expressing cells and the
neighboring cells that might have lower
expression
and there are a few things to think
about throughout this process of
developing drugs and developing these
antibody drug conjugates
um one thing is that antibodies are sort
of large molecules
they're very specific they're designed
to recognize and bind to this particular
antigen and bind tightly
but they do have to find their way
through the bloodstream and to that
Target and that diffusion
take some time uh it's it's not a
hundred percent efficient so you do need
some stability of the antibody itself
you do need some strength and stability
of that blinker to to keep things intact
while it's being delivered to the tumor
tissue and the tumor cells
another consideration is that the
antibodies themselves can retain some of
that anti-tumor power
even though that's not the main goal for
these antibody drug conjugates when it
comes to fighting cancer you probably
want all the help you can get if you can
use the drug and the antibody
why not so an antibody that works
reasonably well on its own is a targeted
therapy might be a better candidate for
the starting point of an antibody drug
conjugate than an antibody that has less
of a therapeutic effect on its own
you might as well give yourself that leg
up when you're when you're trying to to
get one of these antibody drug
conjugates
for example
is an antibody that's used on its own as
a targeted therapy for some breast
cancers
and as we'll see in a few slides trust
usumab winds up being an effective
starting point for an antibody drug
conjugate for those same breast cancers
where it would be used on its own
and that bystander effect is another
consideration that bystander effect can
really help when there is not ubiquitous
High expression of an antigen on your
tumor cells as long as there's
sufficient quantities of that antigen on
some tumor cells
the antibody drug conjugate can be
designed in a way that it can find its
way into that tumor microenvironment
into those High expressing tumor cells
and bring the drug with it into that
tumor tissue to get those tumor cells
with a high expression and
tumor cells that are nearby that might
have lower expression of the antigen
so as these conjugates are being
designed and tested there's a few
different ways to think about optimizing
things and really developing and
fine-tuning these drugs
one side of the coin is the drug
development itself
can the antibody be improved is there a
better Target antigen for the antibody
or once you picked an antigen is there a
better antibody to get
binding to that antigen
or can the Linker be improved is that
link are strong enough to hold
everything together during your drug
delivery process is your Linker being
cleaved at the appropriate time and at
the appropriate location once it's in
the tumor cell is it is it being cleaved
too early
does it does it get the drug to where it
needs to go and then turn it loose
and then can that cytotoxic payload be
improved
is there a different Pathway to be
targeting once it's in the cell you know
is this a cancer specific thing do we
look at the DNA cleavage for one type of
cancer but attack the microtubules and
something else
and then the higher dose do we need a
greater concentration of the drug
or the bystander effect is that
something that for this particular
cancer is that is that a benefit
and then the other side of the coin is
getting the antibody drug conjugate into
the right patients once you've got the
antibody and the Linker and the drug
who does it go to
will this therapy work for this patient
so the question there is what sort of
biomarkers do we have to identify
patient groups or to identify cancer
subtypes
where we're really getting the most
benefit from this targeted therapy
because not all cancers are going to be
the same how can we get this drug to the
the right patient
so with finding the right patient in
mind I'll point out that there are a
bunch of antibody drug conjugates that
have already been developed they've
already been tested they've already
gotten FDA approval for use
and I apologize if I'm overlooking any
with this list there's a dozen or so
here
and these these are not approved for
every patient with all of these cancers
it's not everybody with bladder cancer
everybody with breast cancer these
approvals these FDA approvals are for
certain subtypes of cancer for certain
treatment situations
it's not just a blanket approval
and the two that I'm highlighting here
are both approved for use in some breast
cancer patients and they're both
targeting her2 which is a member of the
human epidermal growth factor receptor
family
and I'll jump into the her2 and breast
cancer here
so as we all know breast cancer is very
common it's the second most common
cancer among women in the United States
right behind skin cancer
and the American Cancer Society has
estimated there will be over 280 000 new
cases diagnosed in women this year in
2022.
but I'll say the Silver Lining here is
that because breast cancer is so
prevalent so common
there's a lot of awareness about breast
cancer there's a lot of research funding
so early detection strategies get better
treatments get better prognosis gets
better and we end up with uh
better survival and just better outcomes
for these breast cancer patients
there are three main subtypes of breast
cancer or at least three main subtites
subtypes that dictate the treatment the
first subtype is hormone receptor
positive breast cancer
this is the most prevalent subtype
accounting for about two-thirds of
breast cancers and it's characterized by
expression of estrogen receptors or
progesterone receptors or both either ER
positive or PR positive or both ER and
PR positive
and these hormone receptor positive
cancers are generally treated with
hormonal therapy
the next subtype and the one I'll spend
more time focusing on is her2 positive
breast cancer
this is less common only 10 or 20
percent of breast cancers and it's
characterized by amplification or
overexpression of her2 human epidermal
growth factor receptor two
these cancers tend to be faster growing
and they tend to get some sort of a
Target in therapy I mentioned earlier
trastuzumab was an antibody that by
itself is a targeted treatment for these
her2 positive patients that have this
amplification and overexpression of her2
the third subtype of breast cancer is
triple negative breast cancer
this is everything else the final 10 to
20 percent that's not hormone receptor
positive not her2 positive so it's ER
negative PR negative her2 negative the
all three triple negatives
and these patients tend to be treated
with other immunotherapies
so back to the her2 positive breast
cancers and that list of FDA approved
antibody drug conjugates that I just
showed a minute ago
these are the two antibody drug
conjugates that have been designed to
Target her2 in breast cancer patients
the one on the left is the older one and
the one on the right is newer
you'll notice they both utilize
trastuzumab as the antibody targeting
her to you which as I just said is
overexpressed in 10 to 20 percent of
breast cancer patients those her2
positives
these two antibody drug conjugates use a
different cytotoxic payload and they use
a different Linker
the one on the right seems to me like
it's sort of a new and improved per2
targeting antibody drug conjugate and
the big difference here is that it has a
protease cleavable Linker which allows
for that bystander effect
and uh new drug itself too allowing for
that bystander effect
so it should be able to kill cancer
cells that either don't express that
her2
or that express it at low levels and
that's in addition to targeting and
killing the tumor cells that do have the
overexpression of her too
so I'll say here that I I don't have any
Financial disclosures or any conflict of
interest disclosures no interest in
AstraZeneca
earlier this year though after
AstraZeneca reported results of a
clinical trial looking at their new
antibody drug conjugate this is the one
on the right of the previous slide
trastuzumab do rocks to can
and this trial looked at her two
positive patients who had received
previous treatment
and the results here are good this is
really saying the new antibody drug
conjugate is better than the old one
that's a really strong result it's
reducing the risk of disease progression
or death by 72 percent compared to the
older older generation antibody drug
conjugate
and as I mentioned this is just for the
her2 positive patients only 10 to 20
percent of breast cancers so great news
for them
but sort of limited scope
the more exciting news came a month
later at the ASCO conference the
American Society of clinical oncology
and this is a different trial this time
they're looking at her too low patients
using the same new drug the same
antibody drug conjugate
and this time they found that the
treatment reduced the risk of disease
progression or death by 50 percent
compared to standard of care
chemotherapy this is really big news
this is like standing ovation at the
conference really really a powerful
result
the previous trial from a month earlier
was looking at the 10 to 20 percent of
breast cancer patients that are her2
positive
this trial is using the same antibody
drug conjugate for a bigger chunk of
patients this is her2 low
and I haven't mentioned her too low
until just now
there was the her2 positive breast
cancer there's the her2 negative as part
of the triple negative and that's
generally the way it's been
characterized uh positive or negative
the clinical test for her2 is
immunohistochemistry IHC
and it gets a categorical score where
the values are 0 1 2 3. the threes are
her two positive
and then the twos if they have a
positive in C2 hybridization test also
get called her2 positive so it's all of
the threes some of the twos
are her2 positive
the rest of them the zeros the ones and
the rest of the twos are clinically her2
negative
but what they did for this trial is to
designate those IHC ones and ihc-2s as
her2 low
so they're still separate from the zero
IHC category which are her2 none her 2-0
but now there's this new her2 low
category that was used for the trial
with a really strong result
and this her2 low category did not get
the older antibody drug conjugate which
was only meant for the her2 positives
I did not have that bystander effect
capability it was really approved for
and used for the her2 positives so this
new one new trial looking at her too low
so on the right side here is a box plot
with its RNA expression of her2 among
tcga breast cancer cases that's the
cancer genome Atlas tcga
the zero one two three her two category
the clinical category is at the bottom
and the left is a long transformed
Counts from bulk RNA sequencing of those
breast cancer patients in tcga
the takeaway here is the three category
on the right those her2 positives
are pretty distinct from the rest in
having higher expression of her2 than
those the zeros the ones and the twos
the her2 negatives
the other takeaway is that the her2 zero
and low the the zeros and then the ones
and the twos they all have some pretty
similar expression to each other there's
a lot of overlap
so that clinical trial from earlier this
year
that tells us the ones in the twos have
high enough her2 expression that they
can be targeted with this antibody drug
conjugate
so the next question is
well what about those zeros how about
the rest of the breast cancer patients
because here this is
the zeros the ones twos threes that's
that's all the breast cancers the her2
positives are only 10 to 20 percent
and that leaves 90 to 80 to 90 percent
that are zero or low
so what about them if this drug is going
to work for the the low group
will it also work for zeros
and I think that's where we'll have to
keep an eye out I'm sure they're working
on new trials and new Publications there
will be more to come
and as this research continues I'm sure
that we'll begin to see more antibody
drug conjugates taking advantage of this
bystander taking advantage of this
bystander effect
and hopefully working towards targeting
a broader pool of patients and uh
getting more people who will stand to
benefit from these targeted Therapies
it's a really old concept you know from
the late 1800s but the idea of
developing a drug or coming up with a
therapy to kill the bad stuff and spare
the good stuff
that's really an elegant powerful
approach to disease treatment and these
antibody drug conjugates are I believe
they're they're a step in that direction
working towards
uh creating a powerful drug with
limiting or removing the toxicity by
getting it to only the spots where it's
needed
as I'm finishing up today
I'll say the antibody drug conjugates
have a lot of potential and in some
cases that potential is already being
realized we've got that trastuzumab
antibody working on its own as a
treatment and as an antibody drug
conjugate that's binding to that her2
receptor on a tumor cell
it's getting pulled into that cell
delivering the drug
and then killing that cell thanks to the
bystander effect the drug is also being
delivered to tumor cells that don't have
that high density of her2 antigen the
the lower expression heterogeneous
expression
so we're seeing a strong treatment
result in the her2 positive breast
cancer patients and that result has also
held up in the her2 low patients as well
which is really really powerful stuff
uh really a credit to the this antibody
drug conjugate design
and uh targeted Therapies in general
so to review antibody drug conjugates
are a separate class of targeted cancer
therapy antibody drug conjugates are
composed of three parts there's the
antibody there's the chemical Linker and
there's the cytotoxic payload
although the antibody can be used as a
cancer treatment on its own in this
situation it's really intended to be
more of a delivery vehicle for the
cancer treatment delivering that
cytotoxic payload
and depending on that payload and the
properties of that drug that you might
see a bystander effect where the drug
can kill cells adjacent to the target
cells that do Express the antigen
in addition to killing the cells that
Express the antigen so it's
it's getting the antigen expressors and
the nearby non-expressors
and that bystander effect as we've now
seen with breast cancer and with recent
trials allows antibody drug conjugates
to be effective even when there's lower
expression or heterogeneous expression
of that antigen
which really offers some exciting
potential for for cancer treatments in
the future
and with that I'll stop there and I'll
say thank you for your attention